this is not talking about tiff i'm
talking about the comments that are
being made
with you guys surmising the stupid [ __ ]
off of the little information that she
gave
and she wasn't it wasn't even a bad
video but you need to know this [ __ ]
information before you go ahead and tear
this down
why isn't bart saying stuff what is he
going to say aside from saying something
that makes tiff look bad
yeah he still cares about her he doesn't
want to [ __ ] destroy her
because i asked him how come you ever
put out a video because the reasoning is
why
how what can i say that makes tiff look
good it doesn't make her look good
in five four three
two one cheers cheers here we go being a
little fancy today
i got myself a little vino and to give
you guys a little background
uh this is this bottle of wine is 120
[ __ ] dollars
i walked outside i see my fiance she was
mumbling something to me i look into her
glass
seven ice cubes inside this wine this
[ __ ] woman
i literally told her this is a very
expensive bottle of wine by the way i'm
not a wine snob i don't know what makes
it expensive but the
but the bottle of wine was sent to me
yeah and i'm like this is pricey it
should be for a special occasion
it's worth a certain amount of money and
i look at her and i see
four or five ice cubes in there i'm like
what did you do she goes it's better
this way
we have cheap wine in our little wine
cabinet
she could have used any of those and she
chose to do it with this
just put some chilled water in there you
gotta just open a bottle of water and
put she's like oh my god you have any
splenda
[Laughter]
how you been ed uh i'm doing okay i'm
doing better
i'm doing uh daily physical
therapy routines uh stretching daily uh
doing rolling exercises hell yeah hell
yeah uh actually stop smoking weed
which is crazy because you smoke a lot
of weed yeah
so uh it's i've been off of it for about
a month now
uh i was telling you earlier like the
weird part about weed withdrawals is
that
the extreme symptoms of consuming too
much weed
kind of happen when you're off of it
yeah i mean not the psychosis obviously
but the paranoia
the depression the anxiety um
gotten over a lot of that but the
[ __ ] dreams i've been having are
[ __ ] wild dude what are some dreams
that you add
so like okay a recent one
so you know i've talked about uh
how you know i i have this old
resentment for the church right
i had this [ __ ] dream that i went
back to my old church that i grew up in
right and it was run down right it was
like
falling apart and it was just gated like
all around with just
thick fence that no one couldn't see
inside it but when i go inside
it's like disgusting and gross
and so um there's a new pastor there
and he's just this korean dude barely
speaks english
and i come around like hey i grew up in
this church
um you know i have a background in this
and that i can help volunteer
and help out right he's like no
you can't do this right and it gives me
a bucket of paint
of white paint right he's like paint the
walls and make it look nice
and i look in the can and it's a potato
what the [ __ ] and i need a potato to
paint the walls white
to whitewash it right and i'm sitting
there
painting the walls white but you can
still see the cracks in the walls you
can still see it falling apart
you can still see just it being decrepit
just painting it white though and i was
getting upset
in my dream and super angry and so i
went to confront this pastor like this
is [ __ ]
i can do so much more than this right
give me more than a potato you son of a
[ __ ]
he's like no just do what i say yeah and
i get so angry i
end up chasing him because i'm gonna
[ __ ] beat his ass
he's running away from me and because of
the stress and anger
i woke up like what the [ __ ] what was he
saying when you're chasing him
i'm so sorry
jesus don't like that
do you need a pigeon
i told my therapist about that dream and
he was like that's everything you've
been telling me about me yeah
like just think about like you st you're
still angry rightfully so
like you see that the foundations of
this church or whatever there's
something wrong with it
but then what they want you to do is
just make it look nice
up front you know and even in the dream
this korean past i don't even know it
was just some made up korean dude
but it was his hair parted to the side
yes
did he have glasses yes
that's like my korean nightmare pastor
right there it was like because
if you recognize like a lot of english
ministries in korean churches like or
young adult ministries they just
cycle through pastors all the time
there's no pastor who's there for life
right or it's like a home community
thing so it's like another new guy who
doesn't give a [ __ ] about me
and it's just wants me to do what he
says yeah and
it's like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i can't
believe i'm having dreams like this
you know yeah and my therapist was so
happy to hear this dream
because apparently he's got some kind of
background in in hypnotherapy oh wow
yeah and he's read a lot about dreams
he's like dude i've been waiting for
this my whole life
that he was just like so excited to hear
he's like i'm so happy
yeah you had this let's break this
[ __ ] dream down
i always have i have like a there's this
note full of like random dreams that i
have
and i mentioned this dream on the
podcast i always wanted to tell this um
this um i wanted to tell this dream to a
dream person because i wanted to know
what they thought about it because of
how weird and psychedelic it was
like a dream interpreter exactly like
i've i've told this stream on this
podcast before about state again for new
listeners it was a dream about
so if you walk into a forest right you
see this big forest
and lights kind of leaking through it
and then when you walk through the
forest you see
this mansion it's not dark by the way
it's beautiful and it's sunny
but it's kind of an old older mansion
like it has like big steeples and steeps
like you know like the cat like
cylinders or whatever so you walk into
this place and
i go in and i walk up the stairs and i
go into this room and
in this room it looks like a preschool
like so you see all these colorful walls
with drawings on it and
like mountain green mountain hills that
are in the shape of a u with the sun in
the corner
yeah i see a bunch of toys i look
forward and i look up and i see this
gigantic robot and
this gigantic robot turns around and he
says something along the lines and i
forgot
i'll read the journal again or the thing
but it was just like run from here or
get out of here
right and he like collapses and he falls
well it was in the voice of our
multi-million dollar friend that i was
just telling you about right
right who is who used to be the former
manager of one of our friends
right so um she's there
and then she turns into uh she's uh
she's a fox she turns into a fox
and he's telling like don't don't trust
her and then so we're running out of
this whole place together we go out
and by the way the details are a little
fuzzy right now i wrote it down but this
is what i'm kind of recollecting
and when we're in this card together
like this fox is talking in her voice
and i'm like holy [ __ ] this is this girl
but towards the end like we go into this
town that has a trailer and there's
like other foxes there but in the dream
basically what happened was i ditched
this person because of the warning that
the robot told me
when collapsing falls over and he's
dying he's like don't trust her
and then i [ __ ] woke up what the [ __ ]
is this weird world
and um like i always wanted to know what
that [ __ ] meant it was so [ __ ] odd
well i i think maybe the preschool
setting was probably
something where uh something you could
trust
that was inviting especially in your
childhood because maybe
um now like you said it was a nice house
right it was like a nice mansion castle
it wasn't like
edward scissorhands all right so
obviously there was an
invitation right it was creepy but it
felt warm at the same time
right yeah and it was probably something
you would have wanted maybe
in your young age right yeah but then um
i think you know it's not saying oh when
you were a toddler maybe
but at a younger age had you you know
this this is some advice
you would have to adhere to yeah before
you had met this person but then you
you didn't ever got that advice right so
perhaps in your subconscious this guy
that you
trust and you respect very much who is a
big
you know guy yeah you know um
to see him fall apart was good enough
you know reason for you to like not to
trust this person yeah
it was so weird though like i i can if
somebody could go into my mind
i could literally draw everything that i
saw it was so weird watching this
and you like also too like the
interpretation of a fox is
your sly like you're slick you're a liar
you know you kind of do things just to
get things out of people too
and that was like the creepy part too
because i've always kind of felt a
certain way about this person too
and like it's weird too because we
actually had dinner
with his mutual friend and i had a
conversation with that after
and i was thinking to myself like the
[ __ ] is wrong with this person
i had to ask him i was like what's wrong
with this like friend of ours
like why is this person literally
laughing at everything that i'm saying
that's like is this person in like the
[ __ ] sunken place like what is going
on
and he just was like overly trying to
compensate for something like
oh i missed you so much or so you're so
this and that and you know for me too
like
i'm trying to be as nice as i can now
i'm not as blunt as before but i
definitely had to make fun of her
while you're eating you know it's like
it was hard not to but i still get that
same feeling from this person it's
always odd
but um what we're all gonna talk about
today and i know that a lot of people
want to talk about this because
um got a few comments it's you know
i'm not really a part of this company
anymore right but everybody knows it
right
they're they're talking about the whole
the
the tiffany exodus from just kidding
films right
right now before we have this
conversation i do want to preface this
for people who are listening
i am friends with both sides and they're
all friends too
and i feel like this situation is being
blown out of proportion by people in the
comments
because i saw the video the video was
not bad and so i was a little confused
as to like what people were so upset
about
because there was there's these comments
writing about oh you guys are supposed
to be families i can't believe you did
that to tiff i was like what did she
what did what did she say that they did
saw the videos very mild
i was like wait it seems like they you
know mutually decided to split
yeah here's where my issue comes in and
by the way
this is no commentary on just kidding
films
barton joe or tiff yeah i have an issue
with the comments
right yeah because of statements that
are being made about a company and about
people even the stuff that people are
saying about tiff
that they don't really [ __ ] know
about like you don't know what the
company culture is
and the crazy thing is that every time
and it happened like it happened once
before in the company right
people make assumptions about the
company without saying anything and then
the
the shitty situation about this is is
that you have you know two people
bart and joe who aren't going to come
out and say like well this is the great
stuff that we've done this is not who
they are
it also looks self-masturbatory yeah
right it looks like you're jacking
yourself
up like oh i'm so great it's just part
right exactly apartment i
put that image in my head
they're just like jacking each other off
after shooting just kidding films you
see the
facebook get really really just reaching
across
they're not going to do that right we
never we by the way we didn't have a
conversation
uh prior to this so i feel like the
things that i'm going to say they're
going to be okay with and if they have a
problem with it we'll talk about it
after and i'm just an
objective third party yeah yeah because
he doesn't know that right i don't know
yeah but you have been on just kidding i
was on just kidding news and it was
uh it was a great [ __ ] time um i
really liked
you know even what came out of it and
what i got out of it to be honest so
uh i didn't see anything like this
coming to be honest yeah
and so let's break a couple of things
down right and i want to break down a
couple of comments that people have made
right
they want to talk about the work culture
in just
kidding films right and they said that
how can you do this to a
to an employee who is an integral part
of you you guys are supposed to be
family
okay we're going to break down that part
too but i do want to set
people's idea of how [ __ ] amazing it
is to work for this company
like if you guys think that this is some
kind of like these two despotic rulers
that are just telling people
what to do all the time you have got
something really wrong
everybody on just kidding films just for
you guys i'm not gonna give you guys
numbers
are paid really well really well um
let's address this then let's talk about
uh a part of her video that people have
been mentioning in the comments and i
didn't look deep into the video because
i thought the video was fine
but i guess people interpreted
differently and one of the comments that
i read was
they were talking about how her she
words in limbo because she didn't have a
job for two months and no
income okay well let's talk about this
for a second
for those of you out there that don't
know do you know how many times
uh how many days we worked on just
kidding films or just kidding news
per month just guess three times a week
two times a week
four times a week two hours a day
we shot three to four days a month
free shot three to four days a month
yeah just kidding
news we boiled it down it wasn't like
this in the beginning
because we shot longer hours but then at
the time we got shot longer we got paid
a lot more too
yeah and people were still fairly
handsomely
compensated now and tiff can corroborate
this too she knows this she had no ill
will towards them
so three to four times a month so when
we have this rhetoric they go
they iced tiffany out for two months i
was like okay
do you when you say i somebody out for
two months not knowing what your job
entails right
they're only working four days a month
you have like 27 26 days
doing whatever you want exactly and tiff
knows this too you could even ask her
she's not going to shy away from this
we would have personal conversation she
goes like i i'm not doing anything for
like the whole week
so she knows about this right yeah and
obviously in her video too
i mean she seems like a little salty
about the situation which of course she
has every right to she
she is moving from a job that she had
with friends and it didn't work out
because they had different interests or
whatever it was personally behind the
scenes that i don't know about right
so i understand her feelings are 100
valid i'm going to make a commentary
about i need people to understand
what the work life is so when somebody
says they're iced out for two months
it's not you're working for 20 days out
of the month
yeah like most people do yeah it's four
days out of the [ __ ] month guys
so the other thing that's very weird
about this right and this is the video
that i saw from her
right um i think people kind of took her
narrative and they started writing her
narrative for her
right that she wasn't saying so i
understand why you're upset with this
too because i
i saw the video too and i was like okay
we went down this way
i guess you know but then by reading the
comments it's like i knew bart and joe
was
yeah i always thought that like how the
[ __ ] did you always
how did you know and how do you even
make that assumption based on what she
said
yeah oh if she's feels like this it must
be this way
no no there's probably an infinite
amount of [ __ ] possibilities of what
it's like
exactly and once again you're making it
clear right now this podcast is brought
to you by june b
matcha if you haven't had delicious
earthy smooth
great junebe matcha you are missing out
matcha is great for caffeine has
antioxidants super healthy for you
earthy rich amazing i have
matcha every morning and i gotta say
it's the best pick-me-up
ever and if people are wondering what
the quality of the matcha that we sell
is like i have literally been there
myself
and i'm telling you right now we have
like 70 year old japanese grandmas that
pick the leaves individually beautifully
shaded to go ahead
and boost the caffeine it has something
called l-theanine which helps release
the caffeine in your system slowly so
you don't crash
to get 10 off your first order of tins
and packets go to junebeshop.com that's
j-u-n-b-i
shop.com and enter code geniusbrain to
get 10 off your first order
that's j-u-n-b-i-shop.com
genius get that 10 off my friends don't
wait on it
and let me know how you like it because
i loves it it is the easiest [ __ ] job
now to tiff's credit she has to do
research and do the articles right yeah
she could say herself like i said i've
had conversations where she's like for
weeks i don't do anything
sometimes she said that she wouldn't
even shower because she's like doing
nothing
so she has a lot of free time yeah right
all right so what's the rebuttal of that
well she still didn't know that she was
in jeopardy with her job
well this is information that i got from
her video and she might have been a very
emotional place because she was very
upset so i understand
yeah but she also said i was iced out
for two months and then she continues
and says
uh i was gone in mexico for a couple of
weeks or two three weeks because of a
family emergency and then she goes when
i came back i had to go to dallas for
another week or two
wait so were you iced out for two months
or did you leave for personal reasons
so within that timeline i don't think
she maybe because she was upset
she didn't understand maybe she felt
that's what she felt
yeah versus what actually happened but
by the way this is information that is
in her video
yeah so she was gone for about a month
within those two months that she was
iced out but you were not here
and then she said that afterwards that
they had scheduling conflicts
so i thought you were iced out meaning
that there was zero communication
yeah about your job also too she did
mention in the video too which
you know once again tiff will tell you
guys this too she
didn't feel like she was within the
system of jk it changed for her she
didn't feel like she was close
or or like close to like the the comedy
or whatever that it was and once again
this is information from her video right
which i understand
she's communicated that to me before too
that you know
she didn't feel like it was the same and
she wanted to move on she has
consistently stated
multiple times that she didn't want to
work yeah she wanted to do other things
which good for her by the way because
she started she they did big mood
yeah right and big mood does really
[ __ ] well on top of that she has her
own personal channel
so when people say like how can you keep
her job and her money in jeopardy
do you guys know tiff makes more than me
[Laughter]
tiff makes more than probably joe daniel
she makes a lot of [ __ ] money
you're i'm like shocked it's like
joe lives in a garage
[Laughter]
he lives in a garage an ant's garage one
of his employees garage
what are you talking about yeah this
dude is broke
he downgraded a whole bunch of stuff
right like i remember
before i moved to washington he was
driving a jaguar and a maserati
right and what's it and then he pulled
up here to do boxing like
yeah like what are you what are people
talking about here as if she's this poor
soul don't don't pity tiff tiff is doing
[ __ ] great
she's doing fan [ __ ] tastic and i
want to go ahead and put this
in a bigger background too since we want
to talk about how terrible
the jk company is right somebody
mentioned and i read this in the
comments and i've seen it multiple times
about i guess in the video i don't
remember this part of the video but
people have said in the comments
multiple times that oh she was an intern
for
a year and a half and she didn't get
paid so here's a little background
information for people who don't know
all right this might blow your [ __ ]
mind you know who else wasn't paid on jk
news or jk news for
more than a year and a half let's say
four to five years who wasn't paid
bart and joe
[Laughter]
so you [ __ ] didn't even know
that did you so the year and a half
that she was interning and once again
she wasn't saying that to [ __ ] on them
yeah it's just to give her an aspect of
how
how attached she was to the company in
the comments that were like oh that's
[ __ ] up yeah that's their narrative
that's not tiff's narrative
yeah bart and joe and i'm pretty sure
they
they don't want to say that i'll say
this for them they were not paid they
didn't pay themselves for the first four
to five years maybe
of jk films they were [ __ ] broke i
made way more more money than them
yeah when we would go out to eat
sometimes i would pay for their [ __ ]
meals i'm not allowed to now bart
last time i tried to pay for he almost
broke my [ __ ] head but i was like
she was broke as [ __ ] let me just tell
you how [ __ ] broke they were during
the time that tiff was an intern
bart lived in his mom's rental home that
she let him live there for free
and then gave joe a discount in the back
studio where he could live at a
discounted price
the only income that they [ __ ] made
is from shows
at the time during youtube those first
four to five [ __ ] years guys
you know how much we got paid at shows
we got paid maybe two or three grand
at [ __ ] most they had to split that
with geo bart
and joe right i made two to three grand
but it was all mine and i split my
manager 10
yeah that's how little [ __ ] money
they made so the audacity for people to
say oh
money [ __ ] changes you four to five
years they did not make take a [ __ ]
single paycheck
funny thing is guess who made a paycheck
in the company though
casey casey was the only paid employee
at the time because
that all their money that they had for
the company and jk films was given to
him
he was the only one that was a salary
person since the beginning till the end
right
but people don't know this because they
won't [ __ ] say it
i mean and that was what i was reading
in the comments like because of
you know the the how she explains the
the fact of uh being an intern or
whatever and they're
and then they turn it like once again oh
i always knew bart
joe cheap or shady like that or whatever
but on the other hand too like i said
once again i'm just the third party
objective viewer on this because i don't
know
i have never had an internship longer
than three months
exactly like by that point it's like
there's a 90-day
period where you're just like hey am i
gonna get paid or not and
for me it's like then i left exactly
yeah and so what happened with this
company too
is that because during this time in the
first four to five years
jk films wasn't making money they were
making sketches every [ __ ] week
imagine doing a dave chappelle type of
show but there's no season break
yeah for four to five years writing new
sketches
right this is what they were doing the
company was not making any [ __ ] money
well one day we were sitting around and
i specifically remember this it was at a
all-you-can-eat sushi spot out in vegas
and we were sitting around bullshitting
like we normally do in the parking lot
having a good [ __ ] time
sitting in the parking lot talking for
three to four hours and then we go why
don't we just film this [ __ ]
yeah look how funny this conversation
people should hear this type of stuff
right
during this time bart and joe are broke
as [ __ ] [ __ ]
they were [ __ ] broke as [ __ ] yeah
right
this is during the time tiff wanted to
intern so
and once again you could even ask tiff
about this and she knows about this too
and she's not gonna
deny this she just had a short video she
can't tell you all this like specific
stuff but i can
so during this time tiff was working as
a
i believe a phlebotomist but she was
working in the hospital and she met
and she was telling us how she didn't
want to work there anymore she wanted to
do other things
she had zero background in entertainment
whatsoever
she didn't she know nothing about
entertainment she only knew casey yeah
bart and g martin gio bart and joe have
a [ __ ] habit and this is one thing i
dislike about them right
a [ __ ] hiring people who aren't
experienced like they always do this
because they always look at people they
go they have potential they have
potential i mean what [ __ ] company
does this dude you hire people who can
help build
but they don't do that they find people
and they build together which is a good
and bad thing right yeah tip was one of
those people that they wanted to help
build because it was casey's girlfriend
they cared about her
and she wanted to be outside of her job
so
she also mentioned in the video that she
was our assistants it was me
bart and joe guess what the reason why
she was our assistant was because she
wanted to
get quit her job and do something
outside of it
there wasn't enough budget in just
kidding films or just kidding news to
pay anybody else because casey was
getting paid we had a few editors and we
just started just kidding news
there wasn't much money yeah and so what
we did is that bart
took a stipend out of his his paycheck
and joe too
and then they asked me on the side which
tif doesn't actually know this either if
i can make her my assistant so she could
have some pay
yeah yeah bless your heart bro and so i
said yes
i didn't need a [ __ ] assistant yeah i
shot a video in my bedroom what the [ __ ]
do i need an assistant for yeah
they asked me as a favor to help her
leave that hospital and hire her as my
assistant
tiff doesn't know that right so when we
talk about this nerve i was their
assistant and i was there um
and was i'm not [ __ ] on tiff i'm
[ __ ] on the people who commented
yeah like tiff couldn't explain this
stuff and you know she said
multiple times and they think how
grateful she is i'm just giving you guys
the data behind why she's grateful
yeah she they could not afford to hire
anybody else
so we hired her as our assistant to do
stuff that we could already do
for me anyways i don't know about bart
bart was actually pretty busy because he
just started barbell brigade so
he needed help a lot yeah so this
is a background of who these bosses are
who you guys are calling terrible
[ __ ] human beings
okay now let's go ahead and put some
more information out just so you guys
know what the workplace is like
so we want to talk about this unpaid
internship right here's a [ __ ] piece
of information that some of you pieces
of [ __ ] [ __ ] don't know
ask anybody who works for a [ __ ]
company right when they were interning
right quote-unquote interning for free
is because there was no money bart and
joe weren't paying themselves either i
wasn't getting paid
the only people that were getting paid
were editors i.e her husband
and there was uh some there was like
daniel quan and a few other people they
were the ones getting the paychecks
nobody else was
we were taking money from anywhere else
that we could so
on top of this we all had a huge brand
deal
it was this company that jeff bezos
started uh it was he was trying to
develop a company that was a competitor
to youtube
well when this company they gave jk a
fat fatsum to repost their content on
their platform
they actually gave me money too separate
from jk because i have my own brand yeah
and um jk took half of that money
a sizable amount of it put it aside
to open up the new office which you guys
all saw yeah that's where that money
went
the other half or the other chunk of it
for people who don't know
for those for that year and a half that
we all entered and didn't get paid
they cut that money for us and split
it percentage-wise to all of us not a
bonus
not uh here's 500 dollars for bonus not
a thousand dollar bonus not a 2003
they gave us a percentage cut of the
biggest deal
that just kidding news had because they
were grateful and
thankful and rightfully so that we
helped out and didn't get paid so it's
like months of back pay
yes it was back pace so it was not a
free [ __ ] internship
yeah it wasn't right and once again tiff
would have explained all this [ __ ] but
it was just a quick video it wasn't for
everybody else to go ahead and go crazy
with this information
you guys don't know this type of [ __ ]
because these guys aren't going to say
it
like they split what company does that
what company gets a huge sum and says
i'm going to split a percentage of my
profits with all the employees legally
they're entitled to just keep that [ __ ]
exactly by the way some people who got
that check don't even know that
i know that because i'm their friend
yeah they don't know that you got a
split percentage of the [ __ ] profits
of a company that you put zero money
into
like this is what blows my mind that's
why i'm getting [ __ ] heated when i
read these comments you don't know the
sacrifice
and how much work they put into to get
where we're at right now
like it blows my [ __ ] mind let me
tell you something else too this gets
even crazier
you know in just kidding news and just
kidding films you essentially have
unlimited vacation
all you have to do is let bart and joe
know when you're going to leave and they
would cover you
because also two people mentioned like
oh she was getting paid project the
project
and she's 100 right but guess what that
was only starting probably 2020 maybe
late 2019
because the company was going under
because of adsense
yes so that's when everybody started
getting paid video per video before that
for nearly three or four years it was
salary based
whether you showed up to work or not no
matter what emergency
i was on [ __ ] the film i was gone for
two to three months
they paid me three months and i didn't
show up for work once
right damn whenever we went on
because they knew i had a project and
they're like david wants to do this film
we're gonna support him and make sure
that he has a check
this is what they did for me during that
film time i actually started quit doing
youtube i wasn't making any money at all
they gave me money so i could pay my
[ __ ] rent oh
[ __ ] nuts yeah guess what else that
was that's to anybody in the company
that was a part of just kidding films
like just kidding news
so and you guys also know too and once
again
tiff can tell you guys this too she you
guys seen on her instagram she was
traveling all over the
place with these major huge brand deals
making fat checks
yeah where the [ __ ] do you think who was
taking over her place
she was still getting a check for com
not coming into jk because everybody was
on salary at the time yeah
because just kidding news was making so
much money so whether you showed up to
work or not you got [ __ ] paid
the the the paycheck the paycheck thing
only happened recently because jk
doesn't have a lot of money anymore
which is why they had to open up a
patreon
there's a background to this and the
reason why it's like that you guys only
got a snip of the [ __ ] story
and you create a narrative that tiff
wasn't even creating she wasn't [ __ ]
on them like that
but you guys decided to once again going
back to
oh here's one part of information we
know so it must mean it's
this yeah right but then like no you you
don't have
all the information you shouldn't be
saying like
oh so that's how it is like young you
still don't [ __ ] know
yeah so let's recap this this is a
company where you were paid salary
whether you were able to show up or not
not even for medical reasons if you
needed to if you were going to go out on
a trip
yeah you were going to be gone for this
week all right you're going to be gone
for this week cool we'll find somebody
to replace you come back next week
there is no other job on earth where you
have unlimited [ __ ] vacation still
get paid for not being there
yeah this podcast is brought to you by
better
help if you haven't been focusing on
your mental health my friends you are
missing out
and guess what better help might be the
thing for you
now i know a lot of traditional therapy
you do it in person but not all of us
are comfortable doing it in person i
actually prefer
doing it online through online means and
even through their app better help
has been a great accessible way not only
accessible by the way also a very
affordable way for me to get
the mental health i need the mental
health i need the mental help
i need by talking to a therapist and a
professional
that will help me sort through my
thoughts and ideas now i got to tell you
being in a safe space
at home being able to do in a schedule
on my own time while being able to
contact my therapist whenever i need has
been super super helpful because
i am very very busy so check
it out visit betterhelp.com genius
that's
better help and join the over 1 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help
that they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states special
offer for genius brain listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
slash genius
for three or four years it was like that
you just get fired you just get
[ __ ] fired yeah so what the [ __ ] are
you guys talking about out there
what are you talking this is [ __ ] that
you don't [ __ ] know hey let me go
ahead and add more to this
out of appreciation and gratitude after
they cut all of us a percentage check
everybody casey can remember chase got a
fat check too
he had a bigger check than i did because
he's been there since day one and he was
a paid employee yeah
after that they took us to a full paid
trip to japan
we didn't pay for that trip guys they
paid for flight
food hotel stay activities
everything we paid zero out of pocket we
were in japan for like a week and a half
damn every [ __ ] employee guess who
else went to
they paid for tiff's kid isaac
you know the best i got from one of my
jobs is like a hundred dollar
like gift card for like employee of the
month and
and one time like um i won some ping
pong tournament so i got tickets to a
clippers playoff game
yeah i mean that's the [ __ ] clippers
in the playoffs guess who else
guess who else was brought on the trip
to japan [ __ ] gina
gina was an occasional guest on jk news
they flew gina out too
right you guys we didn't pay for that
japan trip that trip that you saw all
those vlogs on
bart and joe paid it guess what on top
of that every year after that
we had a trip to vegas full paid hotel
food everything
events shows everything jk paid for it
we had a company trip
to vegas every [ __ ] year so it's like
sounds like
that it was more than an employee that
they cared about this
individual and her family yeah yeah
not only the [ __ ] vegas trip we had
big bear trips too
i mean i see it on instagram like damn
that looks fun
i'm not my [ __ ] cubicle like i'm
dying here
those are full paid jk trips people yeah
this is that's when the company was
making a lot
of money hey let me add more to this how
great this company is to work for
yeah for people who don't know in the
month of december
none of us worked because it was holiday
season
in the month of december we stopped
working and we got paid
full plus bonuses
damn december we didn't work
because they wanted all of us to spend
time with our families which is why we
got to go on trips which is why you see
everybody with their family on on
christmas
and by the way the vacation basically
started
after thanksgiving or during
thanksgiving yeah so basically it was a
month and a half or month in a week
of no work full [ __ ] pay yeah
plus fat bonuses
i mean when you read the comments it
really sounds like tiff is struggling
yeah and you guys made it sound like
tiff is struggling
this is [ __ ] crazy and here's one of
the things too when i saw her video
one of the things that i was a little
irritated at not at her was what she
said was that
bart and joe kind of left her hanging
without pay and i was like okay cool so
i actually messaged them i was like hey
bro in this video
people don't [ __ ] know this i talked
to barton joe about that that was the
one thing i hit him up about i was like
did you not give her like
uh did you guys like libra straight not
give her an exit pay
bro she didn't even say that so check
this [ __ ] [ __ ] out and by the way as
i say this when i talk to bart and joe
about this
there's also other employees that can
corroborate this information and
they'll tell you that this is true
during the month that she was um
gone yeah um bart actually asked her
if she needed money for the checks and
she said that she was fine
because she's doing well at big mood
she's killing that big mother she didn't
need the money she's fine
yeah which is dope because tiff is
[ __ ] killing it
she's a boss ass [ __ ] she's [ __ ]
killing it that's who she is
she was offered pay for that month when
when her grandma was sick and they were
and she said it was fine and they were
having scheduling conflicts because and
they were gonna have this conversation
about her not being
happy in the company because it was
pretty evident you saw it in the other
comments too prior to those videos that
oh tiff doesn't look like she has a lot
of energy
and it's true because for a couple of
years like she said in her video
she didn't she didn't feel like she
wanted to be in the company whenever you
ever worked at a place
where you can openly communicate to your
boss that you don't want to be there
and then still keep your job for two
three years
like when
i mean i got kicked to the curb
immediately when i said i had my year
review at one of my companies i was like
yo i don't like it here either give me a
raise or i'm out
they're like well thank you for all your
work
that's how most company runs yeah so
when you say that jk oh we thought you
were like a family how much more of a
family is that
yeah right i mean my family doesn't do
that
so check this out too and so when i
confronted bart and joe about that
they also said this so during the the
exiting part right
yeah and once again like i said tiff's a
sweet girl she's smart she could agree
with all the stuff too
so they originally weren't even
thinking about letting her go per se
they wanted to see where she was at if
she still wanted to stay at the company
yeah so bart already had in his mind
depending on her financial status
if she wanted to leave if she wanted to
leave or leave the company
he was going to back pay her three
months yeah of salary
so her exit her exit fee was going to be
three months of salary
full salary whoo where in the [ __ ] are
you
where the [ __ ] do you guys go off you
have no [ __ ] information about this
stuff and once again this is not just
bart and joe saying this there's another
employee that can corroborate this
because they heard this conversation
so i had to double check so he he
already was
ready to pay that but once again tiff
already stated that
big mood is [ __ ] killing it she's
making a lot of money so
she's good which of course she's good
guys look at her she's
she's like brand deals left and right
she makes more money than me for sure
yeah i'm still renting she owns a house
yeah i mean i saw her toyota thing too i
was like damn like how come you didn't
get a toyota
i have a toyota yeah you just bought one
like you love your car
exactly i [ __ ] love my forerunner
toyota
i mean like there's just weird how long
have you been begging mcdonald's
i know you [ __ ] know i exist you'll
give me something send me a box i don't
need even money just send me a box or
something
please meanwhile gina got like a chicken
mcnugget bouquet [ __ ]
big titted beautiful [ __ ] that's why
but this is what i'm saying and once
again this is not talking about tiff i'm
talking about the comments that are
being made
with you guys surmising the stupid [ __ ]
off of the little information that she
gave
and she wasn't it wasn't even a bad
video but you need to know this [ __ ]
information before you go ahead and tear
this down
why isn't bart saying stuff what is he
going to say aside from saying something
that makes tiff look bad
yeah he still cares about her he doesn't
want to [ __ ] destroy her
because i ask him how come you ever put
out a video because the reasoning is why
how what can i say that makes tiff look
good it doesn't make her look good
so if people want to say what they're
going to say i'm just going to let them
say what they'll say
is yeah if he defends himself then it's
just going to now be a [ __ ]
more head-butting drama exactly [ __ ]
it's
and i commend it i commend both of them
for just
exactly by the way we me and joe were
just in hawaii with casey and tiff
yeah not that [ __ ] long ago we still
we hang out with we love these people
what the [ __ ] are people talking about
it's sad that at the end of the day that
it didn't work out
but once again think about it it's a
pretty good split
she didn't want to be there for quite a
f quite a few years this is not side
conversation this is like stuff that she
has openly told me that she wasn't happy
being there
yeah and she said in the video and she
said it in the video
yeah and now they split and she said
that she was a little upset about how it
happened
once again from her information she
wasn't iced out for two months she left
to mexico
she left to dallas for personal reasons
all this stuff
and then there was conflict issues bart
and geo live
in vegas and then i'll talk about she
said she has scheduling issues so how
are scheduling issues you being iced out
when clearly you've
communicated enough where you know that
they're scheduling issues so who is
being iced out here
i think maybe her word usage was wrong
right but once again when you're hurt
you're going to say a few things so i'm
going to defend tiff on that
she's probably was you know hurt and
she's distraught that she's leaving a
job that she was at for a very [ __ ]
long time
there's a lot of personal things that
you know people feel when they when they
leave a company they've been a part of
for that long yeah honestly like you
know i felt the type of way when i had
to leave my store
yeah you know and i was there [ __ ]
seven days of [ __ ] week
100 and you know like i had choice words
you know and over time i i look back at
the words i say to him like i could have
used something else
but then it does create a narrative
that causes people to think some type of
way you know and
in the beginning like when i first got
back like you saw how like
distraught i was yeah leaving my store
but i
never wanted you to think some type of
way about my mom
like she was an evil person or anything
like that you know
and so and that's not the way i want
people to hear it yeah and i'm pretty
sure she was trying to be very careful
with their words
so that the people in the comments
wouldn't go out and like hate on them
because she was saying i don't hate them
yeah yeah but then in the comments
they're doing the exact [ __ ] opposite
exactly and you know what the crazy
thing is by the way bart and joe aren't
perfect
none of us are bart and joe have
definitely made mistakes in the company
before
yeah right and of course
who's ever had a perfect boss this boss
stuff too by the way
is also new to them they were never
expecting to grow this company the way
that it did and to have all these
employees
but i will say this and remember guys i
was also a part of just kidding news
and i also left and i also did a video
of me leaving
right but guess how i did it when i felt
that i didn't want to be a part of the
company more to pursue what i wanted
i had a very quick talk with bart and i
go hey bart and joe
hey guys like i can't come on jk i want
to pursue my own things you know what
they said they go
cool man and they gave me exit pay they
didn't even have to give me exit pay i
didn't even [ __ ] need it
yeah and they gave me exit pay and i
left that's also include
brandon also includes julia chow
everybody
yeah so what the [ __ ] are people talking
about about leaving somebody iced out
and not giving them money
like i had no idea that tiff was
impoverished
like when in the [ __ ] have you guys put
this narrative that tiff is somebody you
should pity
as she drives wiping her tears in her
tesla yeah like what what are you guys
talking about right now
has she asked you to pity her like that
what what is this
like where's this narrative coming from
like i mean like are you guys gonna now
send her money
yeah also like to defend tip that's kind
of offensive
like oh poor tiff she's killing it dude
she's [ __ ] killing it what are people
talking about right now
yeah i just to get some info i listened
to the big mood podcast too
in this part and it was so totally
peacefully amicable
yeah and everyone's like yeah being in a
company for 10 years is a long [ __ ]
time it's crazy that you stayed that
long anyway
most people don't stay at their jobs
longer than a year or two
yeah you know and that was the narrative
i was hearing i was like doesn't sound
like any
beef then i read the [ __ ] youtube
comments and it's like
you guys are in your own [ __ ] heads
and maybe because it's cool to [ __ ] on
your boss like because you know
everyone's got beef with their bosses
right yeah
but then you can go on the internet and
say some [ __ ] about your boss
hoping that they won't read it but then
you can also [ __ ] on jeff bezos you can
also [ __ ] on bill gates you can
[ __ ] on all these billionaires you know
and act like barton joe's
pesos yeah talking about [ __ ] joe
living in a [ __ ] garage
yeah wait till they go to the moon you
know wait till they go to space
yeah i gotta tell you and like i said
i'm only like gassed up
because of the comments about people
talking about their work culture
and how bad of a boss they are yeah once
again just so we could highlight this
month of december completely off fully
paid yeah
plus bonuses when the company does well
split
profit on their biggest brand deal with
all the people who interned for free
or helped out without pay to make up for
the back pay that they didn't get paid
yeah bart and joe during the time that
everybody says that they were a free
intern
you guys are also assuming that bart and
joe were getting a paycheck they
didn't take [ __ ] they only got paid when
they did shows
which was so little money and they had
to split it and they had to split it
between three
[ __ ] people they were [ __ ] poor as
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah meanwhile if you show
up as a one-person entity
of your brand then that person gets all
the money but if you're
[ __ ] three people like it comes up
pretty short exactly so when
you know there was a previous employee
talking about the free internship thing
and she also failed to mention that bart
barton joe didn't take any money either
and everything was going into paying the
editors
the video shooters the equipment and
building the company so that you can
put it up on youtube exactly how are you
going to get it up
at all exactly so it's like
the the the audacity for people to say
this about people who have
literally given there's anybody out
there that's been in upper management
that
has their own company is bart and joe
[ __ ] dumb or not
they're dumb because of how much they
gave i look at it
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
don't give me this check are you out of
your [ __ ] mind i don't deserve this
[ __ ]
yeah and that's not me just saying it as
a friend i'm saying giving us a little
too much
but that's what happens sometimes in
these companies they feel these people
who haven't worked jobs outside of other
stuff in entertainment
they feel like they deserve more because
they haven't worked another job outside
of it
man like if you actually work in the
entertainment industry
jk news sounds like [ __ ] heaven yeah
and you've been on set how [ __ ] easy
is it yeah
it's damn goddamn easy exactly and once
again
to give tiff credit even though she
worked four days she also had a research
articles and stuff like that too so
that's that's also a part of her job
yeah but once again four days a week
four days a month yeah and got paid very
handsome
very [ __ ] handsome i can't give you
guys the numbers but it was a lot
i'll give you my numbers and i'll just
say this i
was i didn't get paid as much as her
yeah i got paid to show up
maybe three times a month at the time
for about like three grand or 3 500 a
month
and damn yeah that's fair
but and also very generous exactly and
by the way
not including bonuses not including the
trips that they gave us i even didn't
feel like
i deserved the bonus yeah and once and
you know we even had this conversation
too where they're like oh
you know david will you help build their
company i put no equity in there i put
no [ __ ] money i didn't help with the
scheduling i didn't help with the
concept
i came in and i showed up as a clown and
i laughed like an actor does yeah i got
paid pretty well for what i did
and by the way once again they're like
well if you were on tv show you would
get paid more once again
on a tv show though i didn't make salary
for not showing up
[Music]
they would have found a replacement
exactly get bobby lee on the phone
hey bart and joe i'm gonna be on a movie
for the next two three months that i'm
writing and producing
are you okay cool david we'll still give
you a check and then come back whenever
damn you never
ever ever get that yeah so now that you
guys know the context of how this
company has ran
are you still going to say that they are
[ __ ] money hungry and greedy
when you look at bart's success and the
money that he has that's not from jk
and how can you say they're bad bosses
you don't [ __ ] work for them
exactly like if anyone said my mom was a
bad boss
i'd be like come here those are fighting
women
exactly yeah i don't want to hear that
[ __ ] and once again
this idea of like being iced out which
once again i feel like those maybe tips
like poor choice of words because she
was hurt
and once again understandably so you got
let go of a job that you
not even let go i wouldn't even say she
was let go she chose to leave
she said it herself she didn't want to
be there she said she was relieved she
chose to leave the conversation that
they were going to have
wasn't tiff you're fired it was hey what
do we want to do because you've
expressed that you don't like being here
yeah and her response was well i should
be fired i should leave
she can corroborate this she knows this
stuff it's just
it was just a short video she's not
going to explain this stuff in detail
she's not a terrible person and the
video wasn't that bad
yeah this is the conversation this is
what i don't [ __ ] understand and
people are like oh my god we were such
huge fans you clearly were not
you absolutely were not you love drama
you guys are [ __ ] trauma porn people
yeah i can i can sense that even with
the the episodes that i was on just
reading the comments was just how much
like people were waiting to just [ __ ] on
joe
yeah yeah yo leave them what
what the [ __ ] like i was blessed to even
be on there i'm a [ __ ] nobody
they were gracious and be like hey
you're interesting enough like
you don't want to hear some crazy [ __ ]
too people also forget
the reason why tiffany's saying is she's
also really grateful and when she talks
about gratefulness
she's also saying it too because once
again
in the terms of entertainment she was
also a nobody she was just casey's
girlfriend
yeah and then she was handed the uh the
uh the personal assistant job because
bart and joe wanted didn't have
enough money in the company to pay her
so they did it out of their pocket and
they asked me on the side if i could
hire her too so she could make some
money and then she became somebody
exactly right because of them wanting to
lift her
up when she had the merit do you think
tiff knew how to host
who do you think who do you think taught
her how to host
who aids me who the [ __ ] do you think
taught them we did yeah oh
by the way oh i forgot to mention this
too there's something else how terrible
about how
terrible bart and joe are that they took
their personal channel
jk news and jk films and they posted
the tiffin case trailer to promote their
channel so they could make a living
making brand deals doing other stuff
yeah they're terrible bosses dude
they all promoted their channel that
they're making a fat income off of right
now
in the beginning to help set their
career right outside of this and by the
way people also forget this you know who
helped to start the channel
[ __ ] barton geo yeah yeah coached
them on how to set up format how to do
that was barton geo i was there at the
jk news
where geo and bart were telling about
what they can do and the potential that
they can reach with that channel
i was there this is not me assuming i
was there for those conversations
yeah so what the [ __ ] are people
talking about well i would assume
on a i don't know i i want to say like
from a fan perspective but then that's
not very fan
like yeah to be like this uh
like that's that's what's so i don't
know if i want to say intriguing
or crazy or just [ __ ] up
is just like are you guys fans or are
you guys just like i knew i was right
all that time i was in my head watching
these shows and having my opinions
yeah i mean let's even break this down
right and i want people to think about
this
so i i think maybe in the video she also
mentioned that they felt that you know
the show was better without her and she
also agreed
right she agreed with it okay and
when have you ever known somebody to go
on a platform where you have to smile
and be happy
be good at it when they hate their job
like we were just joking about this
earlier what if like off camera before
we started this podcast
ed comes in right he goes i [ __ ] hate
doing this podcast she's so [ __ ] dumb
like i don't know why i'm even here we
don't even connect and i go five four
three two one hey everybody welcome to
it
the genius brain podcast all right let's
start this chant
yeah five yeah so
oh geez so the reason why i say that i
want people to think about that
is that knowing this do you think
that people in the cast could feel that
energy
she knew it too she mentioned it in her
own video and i don't know why
people aren't even mentioning that part
that she mentioned that she didn't want
to be there for a very long time and she
felt a sigh of relief
so was she let go or did she decide to
leave maybe she's upset because the
conversation was brought up and she felt
that she was going to get fired so she
jumped the gun
i don't know the stuff and that detail
doesn't [ __ ] matter
because it was amicable yeah that is the
point
so when i read these comments about
people questioning
how terrible they are as bosses i have a
very very different narrative and once
again
i also left jk news i also worked for
them yeah
so i am allowed to have this [ __ ]
opinion and by the way i was there for
90
of the stuff so what are you talking
about
if anything else everybody who has left
a terrible comment calling them terrible
bosses and they don't care and it's not
a family
you need to go back to those channels
remove your [ __ ] thumbs down and
apologize to them
you they deserve a [ __ ] apology why
isn't bart saying something why isn't
joe really saying something
because they don't want to make this a
bigger issue and make her look bad
because she doesn't need to look bad
she's not a villain in this
bart and joe aren't villains it didn't
work out she worked for a company for 10
11 years
people change people grow she is doing
bigger and better things with
her own company yeah i mean even if you
are like you know saying such comments
and things like uh oh why aren't they
saying anything why aren't they
responding
those people who leave those comments
don't want to hear what they have to say
anyway they don't
they're not gonna be like oh that's the
other side of the story you know that's
not what's gonna happen
exactly they just wanna see more beef
they just wanna see more trauma
yeah and then they're not satisfied that
um bart and joe aren't going to feed
them oh you guys want to hear something
else too i also forgot this other piece
of information
the pot gets sweeter and sweeter pot
gets sweet
so you guys also know um casey's parents
own a part of uh junebe well they they
franchise the june b
yeah and they actually want to franchise
a couple of more um
depending on how they feel so they're a
big part of this company right yeah
casey also owns a part of june b company
the whole
and so does tiff guess how much money
they put in
no idea zero we gave them sweat equity
wow how generous wow
yeah yeah that they own a part of a
seven figure business
for zero dollars and you know who fought
for them
joe i was gonna say you
know it was joe wow joe fought to give
them a bigger percentage
percentage of the company because here's
something else that people don't know
and i wish they would just [ __ ] say
this sometimes but once again i don't
know how they would
joonbe was also because we're a company
where we do contracted work where
technically we got a salary but it was
we were all contracted
in the sense that we got paid for our
work but they would just give us free
money as contractors yeah
because that's really what we are as
contracted work
it was actually set up as an investment
portfolio as a retirement plan for all
the og members of jk
so if you had any type of money we
wanted them to invest in the junebe not
because we needed the money because
we're already set for investing but we
wanted to give them some of the sweat uh
that's what equity but some of the uh
percentage investment stuff and give
them an early head start while the
company's a lot cheaper
if they wanted to do so well tiffany and
case wanted a certain amount from
the company and they offered a certain
amount of money but it wasn't enough to
give them that piece of the company so
instead we said hey how about you guys
just get sweat equity just post a little
bit here and there and then we'll give
you
we'll give you a part of the company so
they own junebe a part of junebe for
free
a seven figure company yeah
what the [ __ ] are any of you talking
about
about how terrible these people are do
you know a single [ __ ] boss
a single [ __ ] boss that allows you to
go on whatever trip that you want
show up whenever the [ __ ] that you want
say that you hate your job keep your job
and still figure out a way to make your
job work even if the creative
differences were there
gives you sweat equity in a side company
that they put zero investment in
month uh december free with full salary
plus bonuses vegas trips international
trips to japan
you gotta win like an ome sweepstake to
get that kind of [ __ ]
by the way without like even like paying
in to omaze at all like and then get
that [ __ ]
and by the way a job acquired with zero
experience
on the ground floor yeah no production
experience no hosting experience
and they would develop people from the
ground up because
you were the girlfriend of one of our
fave employees and we
loved you enough to give you that job
yeah you cared about her you cared about
her family
cared about her kid flew their kid out
to japan they didn't have to do that
yeah
they didn't have to do that at all they
didn't have to pay for a state they
didn't have to do any of that [ __ ] and i
love that [ __ ] kid
yeah so this narrative that you wrote
for her that she didn't even do for
herself and you vilified these people
you [ __ ] owe them a [ __ ]
apology
because you didn't know any of this [ __ ]
and they shouldn't have to say
all the great things that they've done i
am not exaggerating i'm not making this
[ __ ] up these are just
facts these are facts and you see it all
on you the proof is there
yeah the proof is [ __ ] out there so
as somebody who is a former employee
and also a friend it pisses me off to
hear this because i know so much stuff
that they won't say
because they don't want to jack each
other off yeah like
what and i don't i don't know because it
is a lot for them to say everything
you just said like that that is a whole
lot of masturbatory [ __ ] yeah yeah
i don't even know how they're gonna feel
about me saying this stuff and i'll talk
i'll i'll deal with the consequences
later yeah because at this point i feel
that i
maybe they don't want this information
out but whatever me and bart will hash
it out later on
at the me bart and joe will hash it out
later on all that matters right now is
that i need people to understand this
before you go on this tirade and you
[ __ ] on these people
who have given so [ __ ] much and once
again they are not perfect they have
[ __ ] up in the company too
you know because you know we we're not
they're not bosses normally
right those are responsibilities that
they have to deal with exactly
and they have to apologize they have to
move forward and stuff like that and
they're they're they aren't [ __ ]
perfect
absolutely not there are going to be
employees that don't agree with some of
their
direction and their and the stuff that
they do but at the end of the day
it's based on their dollar and they
built the seventh year company they did
it
so they have to trust their bosses and
the comments you're hearing too is like
what do you what the [ __ ] do you expect
you think
bart and joe are gonna get on their
knees on in front of a camera and
apologize specifically to you
because of your youtube comment yeah not
even what she said what you said yeah
what you said not
not to tiff to what the comments are
saying like they don't give a [ __ ] about
you guys either
yeah you know but they give a [ __ ] about
tiff yeah so they're not gonna go out of
their way to [ __ ] basher
yeah why why do that and let's even put
it in perspective like this
you guys watch big mood you guys know
they had their small company they were
around for a year
they already lost two of their members
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
that's also tiff's company yeah the best
like
you can ask for too is for your fans not
to be starting drama and [ __ ] in the
comments either and say i knew that tiff
yeah i knew that big mood girls was like
this is like no
yeah we're not saying shout out to
either shout out to geniusbrainlisters
minus a couple people who wanted to [ __ ]
oh you should bring tooth to talk
you [ __ ] can get the [ __ ] off
my channel right the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] dude
but thank god for genius brain listeners
or my brain farts out there
that you bring forward you guys are
level-headed and you want to hear about
this [ __ ] but i have to say something
because it bothers me
about this and you know if it was like
three or four comments it's whatever but
i read the comments it's like these
comments are getting thousands of likes
so it's it's a lot of people huh so you
don't even know
you don't even you don't know [ __ ]
[ __ ] i i would assume those
a lot of those likes are coming from
people who
like say yeah i stopped watching just
kidding news
this many years ago i stopped watching
ever since i stopped watching no you did
it you're on the channel yeah and so
like i can see that they're i don't know
if stragglers are the right words
it's kind of like a church split yeah to
this new
side and be like yeah [ __ ] those guys
and they don't even give a [ __ ] about
you they they really don't man
yeah so those people who say that they
were fans and that
you know they knew how they were the
whole time well you now you have a
better picture of how this company ran
and how much these [ __ ]
jackasses were giving to their [ __ ]
employees too much guys
but once again
[Music]
[Laughter]
like [ __ ] man
i'm sorry i'm just laughing that's just
how how much you
really care it's like
so annoying i told these [ __ ] dude
you guys [ __ ] give too much man
what's wrong with you yeah
like it's great right but no anybody who
worked a regular job in production
they came here they'd be like what the
[ __ ] is going on
you're telling me that i can just go on
a vacation to mexico in a month and
you're still gonna pay me yeah and once
again
just to reiterate reiterate this was
before the whole ad poculus happened and
the company was going under
yeah you know and it's just it's just so
[ __ ] hilarious like all this little
bit of drama that stirs up
from nothing that the person made the
video about this like
i i think people in those comments also
don't understand if you worked in the
entertainment business
if you worked at a company i'm not gonna
say like jake if you worked at jk
you know and then you left and try to
find another job in entertainment
good [ __ ] luck trying to find that
money
you will never you're gonna regret
leaving a company like that
by the way there are people that i have
fired into my company because they were
terrible workers
and we had long talks about their
behavior and their work they never got
many seconds they got like three or four
chances and they were out
yeah i've seen these [ __ ] dumbasses
bart and joe
people who are so underqualified [ __ ]
up the job 24 [ __ ] seven used to
[ __ ] frustrate me
and they would i would talk to them and
they would say [ __ ] like they're going
to get better
they're going to get better i'm like
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with you
they're big believers yeah they're like
no no no man
this person's down as [ __ ] they're
family it's like you [ __ ] guys dude i
swear to [ __ ] god yeah i'm just like
they they
went beyond above and beyond to give so
many chances to
a lot of people that [ __ ] up within
right bro and i'll tell you this this is
an employee too i'm not going to give
out names
right a part an employee that worked at
this company
that was so [ __ ] stupid and you've
heard this story before but this was a
jk employee
that watered fake plants for a whole
year
it's going nice and green so happy
he's like just feeling the leaves if
you've heard the story before i'm gonna
say it again because it applies here
this just goes to show how [ __ ]
blindly these motherfu
if anything you guys should be mad at
barton joe for for [ __ ] hiring people
that aren't qualified yeah like
this is like once again too and a lot of
people who weren't qualified turn out to
be great employees and this is what they
bank on because they're looking more at
the person than they are
at their skill set because they feel
that a lot of people can learn on the
job yeah some people can't
this employee during our end of the oh
by the way we would have end of the year
raps where we talk about the positive
stuff
that we did what we loved about this
year before we got our bonuses how
[ __ ] nice is that [ __ ] by the way
yeah actually was so nice he made my
skin crawl
and so this employee during this time he
goes so what did you feel
that you did well guys smiles big smile
snotty he goes
check out the plants
[Laughter]
one of the other employees stands up he
goes you are the one that's been dumping
water into the fake [ __ ] plants this
whole year
i had to clean that [ __ ] up
an office that had no windows yeah
all fluorescent lights in pure darkness
and was watering these plants
basic science states that plants need
photosynthesis
and soil and real soil it's like hey
we're in the middle of a drought
this employee too by the way came to
came to jk with zero [ __ ] experience
and he or she [ __ ] up everything
right and i was watching it and they
just had to deal with the stress you
know why
because this person needed a job yeah
and they needed money
so they kept paying them out of their
pocket yeah
because they needed a job even when they
[ __ ] up because they were like this
dude
has a good heart and because they have a
good heart we want to keep people like
around in this company and they can
learn
just turns out that this guy or girl
couldn't learn
it it seems like this kind of person you
look on with pity because like man
if you where else are you gonna work
yeah if you were out there in the real
world
even at chick-fil-a i think they'd be
tired of your ass oh this person too
um after you know jk um
after this person left the company
worked another job yeah and got fired on
the first day
because because of his fake watering
plant ass
because they found they got so
frustrated because i know the person who
owns that restaurant
got so [ __ ] frustrated because of he
couldn't follow simple instructions
and was [ __ ] people up yeah like
at a restaurant like almost burning
people my gosh
like this is who this person is
this person also because they didn't
have any money
and they they were trying to figure out
like how they can fit in and how they
can give them a job
was given an opportunity to do graphic
work right he wasn't very good at it
either
right so they couldn't do that so he was
like hey like we need to hire a
custodian here i know this isn't like
the best work but if you need the cash
you just have to do like basic cleaning
stuff do the worst [ __ ] ever this guy
vacuumed the office
without the bag so it's just like
blowing the dust out so one of the other
employees came in and they were like
what the [ __ ] are you doing he's like
what there's no bag on it so the dust
was flying out the back of the [ __ ]
vacuum
oh my god oh my god
kept the job for three years before they
had to let this person go only reason
why this person was let go is because
adpocalypse happened and they didn't
have enough money to keep him around
yeah
so when you say that these people just
leave their family out in the dust
it's a complete false narrative what
they do is they hire incompetent people
24 7.
if you want to be mad at them that's a
legit reason to be like hey man
yeah but you know some people who
weren't qualified for the job they
turned out really good
and i think that they're they're basing
like the they want they're expecting the
best out of people
yeah i don't hire incompetent people
because i don't like dealing with that
stuff
i don't deal with that [ __ ] i hire
people who know what they're doing they
could help me grow
bart and joe believe in the best in
people even if they're not
yeah like tiff came to jk news with zero
hosting experience no entertainment
experience at all
they built her up they helped build her
personal channel
geo was the one who started big mood
yeah what the [ __ ] are
any of you talking about i mean it
sounds like
you know like like i said that people
like bart and joe
just believe in the grit of or in the
humanity because it was
that's how we were too we didn't know
anything yeah we had to figure it out
for ourselves so
stupid people like us can do it other
people can too yeah it's like
um that's a really good way to really
like if if you are a good boss you see
someone [ __ ] up and expect them to [ __ ]
up and be like they'll get better
and believing that in yourself in them
when they might not
and be like they'll get better they'll
get better and they'll say they'll get
better after three years
but i mean like yeah i told you this
story let me just even continue the
story even more
this same employee right they were
shooting a sketch
and i told them about this they had to
get um gas for a generator
yeah and i told him the story
guess get a gas for a generator this
said employee was given a gps
they go hey follow this gps the
directions are really simple but they
know that he has [ __ ] up habits
so gave them the gps so it was like hey
when you get this gps
follow it and it's easy all you have to
do is go out and
at the fork you're gonna hit a left and
not a right you go straight down that's
where the gas station is
yeah dude goes got it he goes no no no
take the gps he goes i don't need the
gps
offended that anybody would assume that
he needs a gps because he's [ __ ]
macgyver over here or [ __ ] magellan
magellan he knows
everything he read the [ __ ]
constellation exactly
so he starts driving off this is a grip
truck by the way
he leaves the e-brake up all you hear is
a terrifying screech
like just going and they're screaming
pull the e-brake up the e-brake is so
[ __ ] loud
can't hear [ __ ] keeps going all he has
to do is hit a left that's all we need
he hits a right
disappears for hours oh my god
this that he still kept his job
yeah this said employee like i'm telling
you there's stories
stories all day and once again it has to
do with the fact that
we're also not perfect so we believe
people can
i mean i'm dyslexic i've taken the wrong
turn
there we can understand that
but still like because we live in the
[ __ ] 21st century
and we got gps i won't get lost after a
wrong turn
yeah you know and i don't go missing
four
hours yup you know because of my
dyslexia you know i just have to follow
a blue line this also said employee
once again and this was not even the
reason once again this person was only
let go
because they didn't have the money to
keep the person around
came up to joe and asked for
a raise you've heard how many times this
person has [ __ ]
up asked for a raise they found
another position in the company that he
could do that was very easy i'm talking
about if you found out how much he got
paid for the work that he did you would
[ __ ] your [ __ ] pants
simply because they know that he needed
a job yeah
paid this person to do so
doesn't do his job ask for a raise
simple conversation hey i've been around
this company for about two three years
now i feel like i need to get paid more
cool did you do your work today yes i
did so if i check your word did you do
it
no i didn't
[Laughter]
so last week did you do your job no do
you deserve a raise
probably not thank you guess what it
walks out
do you remember doing that to teddy's
couch why would i do such a thing
yeah i remember doing that
straight up like are you on coke bro
yeah wow
so and you know these are all these are
all [ __ ] hilarious stories yeah
but we're in the company we're all
losers like that and we all deserve
second chances
and you know i only bring up these
stories that you guys
maybe have heard before and i'm saying
it again is for you to guy for you guys
to understand
what type of bosses they are once again
they are not perfect they have [ __ ] up
before too
and we had to solve all these problems
before because they've made mistakes
but you can never ever question about
saying number one say that they're money
hungry and that they're greedy
and they don't care about their
employees because there's not a single
job anybody who has worked at a company
can attest to this that you will never
ever work a job that you are paid
that type of money for that little work
with that many bonuses
for no [ __ ] reason yeah you get to
come in
and say that you hate your job and still
keep your job for two three years and
still be friends
there is no other job like that where
you have zero experience and you were
put at a high position in a company
basically they kept them alive exactly
and now
somebody like tiff is highly successful
[ __ ] yeah tiff
proud of you as [ __ ] yeah so don't write
her narrative for her
don't write her narrative that she's
somebody you should pity and she said
that she was upset about the way it went
down but once again
i'm saying this as just from seeing her
video alone she would probably said it
because she was upset
that she had to leave the company in the
way that she that it happened but once
again
her timeline didn't make sense yeah go
watch her video again and it didn't make
sense
yeah i stout means zero communication
you were in another country you were in
another state and you would you
communicated that you would be out of
you guys tried scheduling it together
and you guys both had separate schedules
bart and geo live in vegas
and it didn't work out and it finally
happened so
and by the way too because i know bart
if they would have said hey this is
super important right now
can we just talk about my future in this
company you could have just got it done
that's how it works it's very simple so
let's not go ahead and vilify people for
the things that they shouldn't be
vilified for
i cannot sit here as somebody who not
only is a friend but somebody who worked
with the company for 10 [ __ ] years
for people to say [ __ ] that just isn't
true it is not
true i was there i left that job we did
it very amicably
it was very easy they gave me exit pay
not just because i'm a friend everybody
who left got the same [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are people talking about
how dare you you owe them a [ __ ]
apology
yeah i mean like i
i had a i had an experience with a past
company
where uh one year i had a yearly review
and they were like you've done so much
and saved this company
so much so many times because
i wasn't just an editor i do after
effects too there's so many [ __ ]
cg jobs that i had to do that's outside
of my [ __ ]
you know um job description you know
to have to save this company from brand
deals and such and such
that um that they gave me a great
raise one year and they said by next
year we're gonna bump in another 20
percent
right and then i was like [ __ ] yeah you
know
and even i was like yeah i can't wait
for that i stay but that company for a
year my next yearly review came up
and they were like no we're not going to
give you that
you know and i [ __ ] left
yeah you know i [ __ ] left and it's
i don't know how to say it because
except that's just the way the cookie
crumbles
yeah right i said hey you said that you
were going to give me that
my problem was that i didn't get it
written
you know in stone i guess or whatever on
a contract on paper anything
and i had to deal with that was i sour
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah i was sour about
that
um but you know what else i knew too
though
was like what who i was and what i'm
capable of
and the fact that i've had so many
people calling
and asking me you know hey will you come
to our company will you come to our
company will you come to our company
and i let them know that too hey other
people are calling my name
do you want to give me that raise you
said you're going to give me or just
have me leave never like
said the same thing we're not going to
give it to you you know and
i was friends with the ceo when the
company was 50 people i
[ __ ] shared a desk with him i'm
editing he's doing ceo work
yeah and then it grew to like 700 people
and so i was like you know i'm gonna
send my goodbye email
and then send me back an email hey come
to my office right now yeah
and you apologize like i'm sorry like
that you're not getting that pay but
then like
i hired this vp for a reason you know
for her to do her job
and it would be complete nepotism for me
to just because i want to give you that
money
i want to give it to you but i just i
can't do it it's not gonna
it's she's gonna probably quit because
of that all that they laid it out
we talked about it and i said i get it i
understand
and there's another company that's going
to give me the money yeah and you know
what so i [ __ ] left
yeah you know sometimes guys like yeah
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
burns yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] hurts
you know but you know if you're just
gonna look at
you know the narrative that's quote
unquote then yeah you have every reason
to say
[ __ ] that old company and throw the bad
bosses and those liars and two-face
whatever say what the [ __ ] you want
what was i gonna do by like remaining in
this
squalor and being like all these
[ __ ] or moving forward and
moving it ahead with my job and going to
my next gig yeah you know and and just
you know we all got to work we all got
to survive i am not
better than the hand that feeds me yeah
you know
yeah like and also too it's like having
said that
do you think that your attitude at the
work would have been perceived as a good
attitude
people would sense all that [ __ ] yeah
you know once again
tiff said that she was relieved yeah so
it was very amicable
that girl is killing it she's doing a
great job in the stuff that she cares
about
like and it's not like after she left jk
he's like
she's losing what four days of work you
had 26 other days to do whatever the
[ __ ] you wanted
yeah all of us did yeah you know now
let's
just to frame it though when we were
first doing jk it was a lot of work but
once again
it reduced the amount of episodes we put
up and then on top of that now
um they we also got compensated well
after the bonuses we kept on getting
these major bonuses
the bonuses i got were [ __ ]
ridiculous like i mean they more than
cover the back page oh for sure they did
you know for by the way it's like three
four days of work a week a month
so yeah the back pay was pretty [ __ ]
good you know
and also too like i probably got paid
more than some other people because i
brought my fan base to their channel
because i was already established before
jk news yeah and the only reason way
this could be a problem is if tiff died
and then never saw that back pain
yeah if somebody died and then like oh
there's this money they could have got
you know they died because you didn't
pay them you know martin joe it's like
that's not the way it happened they made
sure that
they could live yeah right like and they
gave him a living yeah and remember guys
it wasn't mentioned in her video but
once again it was a very short video so
why should she have to mention this
but the conversation was
what can we do like you're not happy
here it wasn't you're fired
it was you're not happy here and then
the conversation was hey we're gonna ask
you
how you are financially and she's fine
of course she is
yeah and said she didn't need the money
it was what she said
so you don't know these parts of the
story right and it's not tiff's fault
it's not his fault that she didn't say
that it was a short [ __ ] video yeah
so don't even blame her for that either
things are fine they're still in the
same company we still have june be
together the stuff that they have sweat
equity and they put no money in and that
they own
so things are perfectly okay
casey shoots the content in the videos
he's a creative director at june b and
that's his sweat equity and then tiff
comes along that's it and then she also
owns a part of it
that's pretty [ __ ] sweet so i mean
we're gonna wrap the podcast at this
point too there's a lot of information
that i divulge to everybody that most
people don't know
and you know barton joe doesn't like the
fact that i put this information out
we'll have a conversation later about it
but it's already out so this is going to
go up pretty soon
because i need people to understand this
and i want apologies from everybody
yeah i want to see you get on your knees
and be i'm a society i want you to
[ __ ] get on your hands
i want you to raise your hand to the
wall and hold it there for like four
hours for four hours now if you see you
drop that [ __ ] i'm gonna beat the [ __ ]
out of you elbow straight [ __ ]
yeah leave tiff alone leave bart and joe
alone
and [ __ ] apologize the next time i
see a video i better see [ __ ] 10
000 likes on their [ __ ] video because
now you know the type of bosses that
they are
don't you [ __ ] dare not as my friend
but as somebody who's a former employee
and has watched
everybody work that i wasn't a former
point for a couple years i was there
since the beginning yeah i didn't get
special [ __ ] treatment
everybody got treated the same yeah bart
effect beat the [ __ ] on me a lot of
times i hated it
until i learned how to [ __ ] do some
jiu jitsu when i boxed now
now it's still not even but still i
could defend myself a little bit
you know but anyways guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
i hope you enjoyed it
[ __ ] all you [ __ ] not my not my brain
farts you guys are fan [ __ ] tastic
great thinkers too shout out to somebody
else i forgot your name but he wrote
this comment that i really liked it was
he wrote david like you did something in
my life that helped me change for the
better
i don't even like or or agree with 70 of
[ __ ] that you say but
you know i think we could all agree to
disagree but i still love listening to
your stuff yeah man
that's some [ __ ] real [ __ ] dude yeah
some objective listening man
and not like an emotional like oh well
[ __ ] david
yeah cause they just hop in the
conversation like yeah i don't agree
with that but they don't get emotional
about it
when people say weird [ __ ] i don't
[ __ ] get emotional about that [ __ ]
either i'm just like okay i get it
yeah i mean i mean i know we want to end
but then i literally
uh i posted that you know there was that
skywriting in la that said joe rogan is
literally fifo oh yeah yeah yeah
and then i posted another meme after
that showing he's more or less maybe
five
six in reality five seven you know and
then i got a
i got a dm saying but joe rogan is a
terrible person
and so i was like look he says a lot of
[ __ ] this and that but then he brings on
the smartest minds
the the best educators the the most like
the people who are
at the top of their game people he
disagrees with people who he disagrees
with
but then there's just people who just
paint him as
whatever they think they are you know
and those are the dumb [ __ ] who
are painting bart and joe this way
yeah you know and guess what blocked me
like i haven't heard from her since of
course you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about that's why well
guys you can find ed park
ed parkvp see him on instagram and you
could see him on his own podcast
uh bible study at moma i'm working on a
new episode and people keep asking me
for one but i've just been [ __ ] lazy
you piece of [ __ ] yeah
but i'm working on a new episode yeah so
check it check that out check out his
stuff and then we'll see you all next
time
we're gonna talk about space jam okay
we'll do that next one